do you need to learn nscap fast today
that's exactly what we're doing with the
brand new nscap for mac and we're
pairing it with aryad 27 to make you an
endcap expert best of all we're going to
be doing it in under 15 minutes are you
ready me too but first we need to thank
the sponsor of today's video chaos the
company behind andscape that's it no
sales pitch just a company looking to
nurture upand cominging Talent like
yourself with a free 14-day trial for
those that don't already own andscape
now we're truly ready let's go now that
we have Arad 27 open on our computer we
can get started with today's nscap
tutorial the first thing that you need
to do in Arab 27 is simply go up to the
top once you've installed andscape
because it is a plugin and not a
standalone program select andscape and
hit start once you hit the start button
the nscap window will load as well as
the andscape tool bar within arat if
your toolbar doesn't appear for whatever
reason you want to come up to the top
window pallets and turn on our andscape
toolbar which is this little guy right
here if we snap it to the side of our
palet it's going to be very convenient
to use now personally I don't have two
screens so I like to split my
environment 50/50 now let's dive in to
the basics of inscape and move quickly
so you can achieve this in 15 minutes
first of all with this palette we want
have our views synchronized so we simply
select this camera with the two arrows
which means every time we move in aryad
our inscape window follows fantastic and
so easy to use personally I like to
start my experience within the ncape
window this way we can actually control
our environment set everything up first
and then start creating our actual scene
I find it so much easier to select and
create your hdri skies and background
before you start selecting colors and
textures and materials because when the
sky is different Everything Changes
let's come up to the top to this little
visual settings icon at the top it's
just an eye with a slider hit that
button and we're going to see our main
visuals presets panel open up now
personally you don't need to change the
style or any of these to create a great
render keep that as none the camera Auto
exposure we will adjust later on when we
select that HDR sky and we'll come back
to this we can move across to image but
we will come back to this at the very
very end so next we're going to move to
Atmosphere personally I don't like any
fog in the background so I turn that off
entirely and with illumination we'll
come back in just a second as well we
want to come across to our sky so we can
select our hdri background in the
background we want to select the source
and change this to
Skybox once it changes to Sky Box we
want to load something from our
downloads personally I've just
downloaded this from hdri Skies you can
get your HD Skies from anywhere you like
so now that I've imported my sky you'll
see the background has come in it is
very very dark in this instance so to
make sure we can compensate for this we
simply drag up our Lux levels until
we're relatively comfortable with the
scene we've created for me personally it
is quite dark still and the hdri map
I've selected probably isn't the best
one possible so so we are going to have
to increase it to about 21 22,000 lucks
to be able to have a good scene rendered
out now we are still able to move in
nscap Freely by left clicking on the
mouse using the wsd and W keys of course
we don't actually always have to do that
in aryad so we do have the free reign to
do it in both software we can move
through these sliders one by one until
we are happy with the scene for me
personally I'll work through these
quickly and that you guys screenshot it
this is roughly where I think the
perfect settings are for this hdri sky
so if you want to take a screenshot of
that you most welcome to next we're
going to come back to our Sky Box and
actually change the rotation so our
shadows align exactly where they need to
be now you see I'm swinging this
rotation and nothing's happening that's
because the brightest point is not set
to the sun Direction so you want to make
sure that is turned on and now when we
rotate our shadows rotate with our
background as well for me in this seen I
want to emphasize this caner lever below
our actual structure so to be able to do
that effectively I need to adjust my
angles of the Shadows to be able to
actually emphasize that finally we want
to come back to our image settings and
simply create the best contrast
highlights and shadows we possibly can
now obviously you can click Auto
contrast and it will brighten the whole
scene it depends what kind of atmosphere
you're trying to create remember
rendering is all about emotion and how
you can evoke the emotions so by doing
individual F tuning we're going to
create the best outcome possible same
situation I'll fast forward here and you
can screenshot at the end there we go
that is our visual settings completely
set up meaning we can go through and
start creating that camera angles now
most people create their camera angles
at the end I like to create them at the
start to know exactly what we're
creating to create our camera angles we
need to go through this meticulously
first we open up our view Management on
the left hand side or we can press the F
keyy to open it up rapidly next we want
to create our first view so if I adjust
this approximately here we're going to
be able to change this in a second let's
create our first view let's call it
front on we're not going to link any
custom presets we're going to save all
of the Suns positions and I'm going to
click create it's going to take a few
seconds to create that view but we're
going to see that in the next house we
have that front view created so if we've
ever moved away from our actual
perfectly aligned camera angle we can
simply click on that front view and it
will automatically Swit back now what
you'll notice and I've done this on
purpose is this isn't aligned to what we
just saved 30 seconds ago and there's
good reason for that first of all we
have not introduced our safe frame so
clicking our safe frame is going to turn
on what you're going to see render
export quality in our settings we've got
this set up as most likely the 2K a 4K
export very very traditional now
personally that's a great scene I don't
mind it but you might be wanting to
export this for social media so if
that's the case you want to open up your
visual icon settings again go to output
and change your output settings we can
change this to Ultra HD which is 4K
export resolution or custom where we can
change it to a 2000 by 22,000 grid
perfectly aligned to an Ultra HD image
in Instagram if you're not happy with
the camera setting you've set up what
you need to do is hover over the view
you're not 100% happy with click on the
little edit icon which will open up our
edit View mode in this instance we can
fly around adjust exactly as we need to
so maybe in this instance I actually
want the camera to be a little bit
closer a little bit more centered and
more of a drone shot than from the
street view once you're happy with the
positioning you simply press save once
again and it will up dat that
immediately it's exactly the same
process for creating all of your other
views but in this case let's say we jump
into Arad we want to have our position
approximately here that looks great in
Arad that looks great in ncape it's
automatically sync those views together
because we have live view activated we
can come back to inscape we can create a
new view let's call that left side and
press create now we have our front and
our left side automatically created and
if we select either of these it can
rapidly jump between these two views
that we've saved now as you can see in
andscape if I drag this wider this is
already an incredible render that we
could export straight away and it would
be half decent for no work at all
because ncape has some great propri
technology that's able to import your
model and create something phenomenal
but we're looking to be an endcap expert
so we want to take this to the absolute
Next Level we can do that through the
endcap library and materials so coming
into Arad I'm going to turn off my live
view so we aren't constantly messing
with two screens now to make this
incredible we want to start with our
materials first materials is super super
simple to do in ends scape first of all
you want to open up your materials
editor it's this clear looking Circle in
the endcap palette now we have all of
our Arad materials already imported into
nscap straight away basically endcap has
been Pro programmed in such a way that
it integrates into your workflow so that
once you've set it up once you've create
the skeletons and the templates you can
jump into endcap and render out in
seconds the first time you're creating
and using may take a little bit longer
but once you've done that it is a smooth
workflow so as an example I really don't
like this brown Timber anymore I would
much rather see that in Black so what I
would need to do is actually change the
material in Arad not change the material
in ends scape what we do then is open up
our settings in Arad and let's simply
make that monument in black and if we
move our little inscape material we'll
see in endcap it's automatically changed
to a very dark black scene now like I
said this material editor is your best
friend in ncape what we want to do is
find that Monument color open it up so
we can start editing it specifically for
nscap the texture itself applied is
simply a monic color so it makes makes
it super super easy to work through this
basic material editor on the right hand
side we have a number of Sliders that we
simply work through and watch line of
adjustments happen on the instate window
so if we zoom in to this black texture
we can see it's just way too black you
can barely see anything on it without an
immense amount of light on it for us to
be able to make this work a little bit
better we want to adjust some of these
sliders so by adjusting the image fade
it will make it lighter or darker by
adjusting the roughness slider will
either make it smooth shiny or harsh
rough now this could either be a metal
cladding or it could be a Timber clading
in this instance maybe we want it a
little bit shinier so that we could see
it a little bit more and maybe we wanted
to increase the metallic as well
personally still I think this is still
way too dark for this scene now luckily
we can adjust that in the color settings
by simply adjusting our sliders making
it lighter removing that texture
entirely
and there we go we've got a nice shiny
metal cladding on the front which is
also perfect for our window frames that
process is repeated for all of our
textures to be able to make them a
little bit better so this roof for
instance is just render white but maybe
I don't want it to be white maybe I want
it to be a lot more of a concrete
texture so what I'd actually do is again
in Arad go through and change it all to
concrete now that the roof and the walls
have been changed to concrete it's
automatically adjusted in endcap but I
still want to find tun it in my material
section so we come back we find the new
concrete we created and potentially we'd
like to add a tint color and if we do we
can simply select that tint and start
adjusting these sliders ever so slightly
to perfectly create what we need now if
we think this texture is too small we
can select the actual texture map
increase the width and increase the
height to be able to actually increase
the size and scale in ends scape so for
me one probably is enough but two is
perfect it is concrete again so you want
it to be extremely rough you don't need
it to be metallic at all and we have no
transparency on this texture we can
continue that with our glass and our
pool and our Earth and all of our
concrete as well to be able to fly cheed
everything but instead we're going to
move on to objects and I'm going to show
you exactly how you can create the
perfect objects in this gape so we close
this pette and select this little tree
icon up the top it's the asset library
inside the asset Library you have
hundreds and thousands of different
assets available to you directly
imported into your aryad model now
here's a pro tip do not allow these
assets to Simply drag and drop into any
Arad layer make sure you create a new
layer either under 3D presentation or
inscape call it whatever you want and
make sure all of these assets are placed
into the correct layer so that you can
individually turn them off and on
presentations and construction drawings
do not let them go anywhere you'll cause
yourself a headache now vegetation
obviously plays the biggest role in any
good render luckily for us andscape has
920 selections makes it super super easy
if we don't want to have 920 scroll
through we can select our tags and we
can fine tune it so maybe we want to
look through over 300 different
beautiful trees let's say we want to
place one of these trees so we double
click that pallet will disappear and we
want to place that tree right there so
we click once in aryad and it will
create that tree for us full 3d inside
aryad now here's where andscape becomes
super super powerful without having to
go into the program we can select this
tree move it like a standard object in
Arad drag it drop it down to the actual
natural ground level then we can come to
to our floor plan and that tree will
also appear in our floor plane so we can
select that tree we can duplicate it a
few times like any other object in aryad
come back to 3D multiple trees are
available to us straight away that one's
turned into a bush so we need to
increase it a little bit higher come
back into andscape and you'll see all of
those trees have immediately appeared
into our model now we can open that back
up we can unselect trees and maybe we
want some people in our scene let's say
we want a man walking alongside the
driveway just over here it will create
that man for us we can drag and place
him perfectly in the scene same
situation with vehicles props anything
your heart desires you can find it in
the inscape asset library now if I
scroll through these cars we have a
great selection we even have a cyber
truck so this is updated quite
frequently maybe we want yellow
Lamborghini simply double click it press
it once enough cat and it will create
this Lamborghini for us and of course we
can adjust that in 3D in 2D how we like
rotate it select it we have our object
in Arad coming back to endcap we have
our yellow Lamborghini as well now once
you've gone through and done that series
of events for every material every
texture you could end up with something
like this we've populated thousands of
plants into our planter boxes including
some beautiful cacti as as well as
provided a background with natural
Greenery and vegetation we've been able
to introduce a couple characters into
our scene that beautiful Lamborghini to
make that black scene pop as well as
fine tune all of our concrete settings
perfectly all we need to do now is
Select our Front Street View line it up
export it and we've completely mastered
everything there is to know ncape and
icad 27 the mac and under 58 unes